عندما كانت في الثلاثينيات من عمرها بعد
ولادة طفلها الأول ، أصيبت
روبن سولار بالمرض عندما أكلت
أي شيء تقريبًا ذهبت إلى الطبيب
عدة مرات وأخيراً
قمت باتباع نظام غذائي للقضاء
على الطعام وكانت النتيجة أن روبن كان عدم تحمل
اللاكتوز وهو عدم تحمل اللاكتوز.  اضطراب شائع جدًا
هو في الواقع عندما يكون لدى الشخص
نقص في اللاكتاز
وهو إنزيم يتم إنتاجه في
الأمعاء الدقيقة
ويفكك السكر في الحليب
المسمى
اللاكتوز ، ويمكن أن تتطور الأعراض في أي عمر
قد تشمل
آلام في البطن وانتفاخ غازات البطن
والإسهال و  حبوب لاكتاز الغثيان قبل
الأكل قد تسمح بتحمل بعض
الأطعمة
وتجنب الحليب ومنتجات الألبان أمر أساسي
ولكن الحصول على ما يكفي من الكالسيوم وفيتامين د
مهم أيضًا ما نوصي به هو
أن
يأكل المرضى الأطعمة التي تحتوي على نسبة عالية من
الكالسيوم ثم قد يحتاج بعض الناس
إلى تناولها.  مكمل من
الكالسيوم وفيتامين (د) يقول الأطباء أخيرًا
إن الأشخاص المصابين بهذه الحالة يمكنهم الحصول على
كمية صغيرة من اللاكتوز في وجباتهم الغذائية
تقول سولار إن إجراء تعديلات على
نظامها الغذائي كان أمرًا صعبًا
، فقد تعلمت ما الذي
يناسبها في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم ، أنا نانيت سوسا ،
اذهب وخذ ذلك إلى المائدة